[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui, Internet est devenu un
outil vital pour survivre et il est sans aucune
profondeur devenu extrêmement difficile d'
imaginer un monde sans il est vrai
que oui, c'est que nous avons vu de nombreux
avantages d'Internet, mais la
question est de savoir combien faire  nous connaissons
vraiment Internet la profondeur la sécurité
la vie privée est-ce un champ de bataille géant
imaginez peut-être un monde qui existe
sous la surface de la blessure un monde
différent de ce que nous voyons dans la
vie de tous les jours un vaste sous-sol qui est
plus grand que tout ce que nous avons  jamais
imaginé ou vu auparavant un endroit où
personne ne connaît et l'endroit où
vous pouvez rester complètement anonyme
où vous pouvez faire et dire ce que vous voulez, mais
ce monde a également un côté sombre, il
grouille également de criminels à cause de
l'anonymat et de la vie privée qu'il  est un endroit
où les gens pourraient bien faire des échanges illégaux
ce monde iDEN existe réellement
c'est un monde d'internet c'est l'
abîme d'internet que nous allons
découvrir tout de suite  t maintenant ensemble, Internet
consiste en bien plus que ce que nous voyons à
la surface en fait, le Web tel que nous le
voyons réellement ne représente que 4%
des pages Web en réseau comme nous le savons
comme Google YouTube et tant de
chatons mignons non comme un chat endormi  ou même du nouveau
porno, mais
sous la surface se trouve le vaste
sous-sol numérique, le Web profond et sombre,
c'est un endroit où les gens peuvent
exprimer librement leur opinion dans cette
communauté anonyme, mais aussi un endroit où les
barons de la drogue, les pirates, les terroristes et aussi - les
acteurs peuvent effectuer des transactions illégales.
la vérité est sur le Web invisible, vous pouvez
acheter toutes sortes de drogues dont vous ne
soupçonniez même pas l'existence avant de pouvoir acheter des
armes que vous n'avez déjà
vues que dans le film de Jason Bourne, vous pouvez
même acheter autant de cartes de crédit volées que
vous le souhaitez pour peu  de 5 $ par
carte de crédit pour payer votre arme toute cette
activité illégale peut se faire derrière
un écran d'ordinateur dans le confort de votre
propre maison assis dans votre canapé c'est si
simple et je n'ai même pas commencé  pour parler
de l'accessibilité de la pédopornographie ou de l'
obtention de ses hommes pour tuer votre pire
ennemi oui il est possible que
vous pensiez que c'est déjà un
cauchemar c'est juste le niveau un du canard
internet je vous propose d'approfondir
parlons du merveilleux et du magique
monde de l'Internet des objets Wow
semble plus fantaisiste est très simple de définir
l'Internet des objets comme un réseau d'
objets physiques connectés
à Internet les entreprises vendront
ce type d'appareil vous savez
qu'elles essaieront de vous vendre en tant que  histoire
qui a l'air connectée ce qui va
changer votre vie wow c'est un
flux sans fin d'appareils connectés de plus en plus
chaque jour l'exemple d'aujourd'hui
votre smartphone votre téléphone ne peut
pas suivre exactement
où vous êtes il peut surveiller vos
habitudes de sommeil et combien de pas ont  vous avez
fait pendant la journée votre montre peut
mesurer la température de n'importe quelle pièce où vous
êtes ici ou surveiller votre abbé elle a enseigné
toute votre vie personnelle elle stocke votre
vie demain yo  votre réfrigérateur
pourra partager ce que vous mangez, votre
téléviseur partagera ce que vous regardez,
etc. et l'imagination des appareils connectés
est la limite, mais en fait, nous sommes assis dans une
vulnérabilité inutilisée car tous ces
appareils ne sont généralement pas sécurisés de par leur conception.
c'est un  merveilleux terrain de jeu
pour se produit aimerait jouer avec car
vous imaginez jamais que quelqu'un vous espionne
via la webcam de votre ordinateur portable si vous
connectez une webcam juste pour des informations,
vous ne pouvez attendre que 6 secondes si vous
collectez une webcam directement sur
Internet, vous pouvez  attendez au moins 6 secondes
et il commencera à être infecté par des
documents
Snowden malveillants.  a même un surnom ça
s'appelle programme du nerf optique tu peux vérifier
sur Wikipedia si tu veux alors n'oublie
pas de sourire la prochaine fois que tu seras
devant ta webcam bonjour  n'y a-t-il pas une
capacité illimitée de connecter des choses
à Internet, ce qui nous rend plus vulnérables
aux attaques un roi se présente sous de nombreuses formes et
cela se fait pour de nombreuses raisons pouvez-vous
imaginer des raisons argent activisme terrorisme
même adolescent peu qualifié malveillant Acker
comme la capacité de mener le
plus  activités descriptives et graves
que vous pouvez avoir un impact massif le
premier exemple que je vais donner est une
cyber-attaque utilisant Internet de couler
le soi-disant appareil connecté mot si fantaisiste en
ce moment comme vecteur d'attaques
il s'appelle peut-être l'attaque Mirai  vous en avez
entendu parler
le Mirai est un malware qui infecte des
appareils comme la webcam ou le Reuters personnel
celui que vous avez à la maison exactement le
même et transforme ces appareils en
zombies mais ils fonctionnent toujours
normalement vous remarquerez tout ce que ces
zombies appelés
un botnet attendent simplement  les ordres d'attaque
spécifient une cible désignée spécifique et
cela fonctionne cela fonctionne très bien et vous savez
ce qu'il a même perturbé Internet pendant
10 heures en  Amérique du Nord en octobre dernier,
il y a quelques mois à peine, rendant des sites
comme Amazon Twitter Facebook et CNN et
accessibles essentiellement, il s'agissait d'une
attaque utilisant des produits de consommation afin
de casser Internet, nous pouvons facilement
imaginer demain votre
téléviseur connecté non sécurisé ou votre réfrigérateur connecté non sécurisé
attaquant le SBI  sites web nous
serons responsables de vous ou de votre frigo
en janvier 2010 la première arme numérique au monde a
été lancée elle
s'appelait Stuxnet les piles de filets ont causé
la destruction physique d'une
centrale nucléaire iranienne puisque ces
capacités techniques ont été développées
et automatisées de manière significative elles peuvent maintenant
infecter les systèmes  dans le monde
six ans plus tard automatisation Stuxnet après
automatisation, il est désormais possible que n'importe quelle
agence gouvernementale puisse littéralement
fermer n'importe quelle infrastructure critique de n'importe quel
pays à tout moment aux États-Unis, par
exemple,
cela s'appelle agenda le programme agenda est
un service de numérisation qui recherche
ports ouverts
sur tous les serveurs publics  Partout dans
le monde, ce programme est utilisé pour faire du
renseignement ou perturber
l'infrastructure d'un pays entier.
Plus récemment, les Russes auraient agi contre les
États-Unis.  élection présidentielle, vous en avez
probablement entendu parler, s'il est vrai, cette
cyberattaque deviendrait une énorme
menace pour le processus démocratique, mais en réponse,
il a été confirmé que les États-Unis ont
pénétré le réseau électrique russe. Je
pense que ce pauvre donne à un pays la
capacité de couper l'électricité
d'un autre pays en décembre donc
janvier c'est le milieu de l'hiver maintenant
pouvez-vous imaginer l'implication que cela
aurait sur les civils les tensions
s'intensifient très rapidement c'est le meilleur
et le plus récent exemple sur la façon dont la
cyberguerre peut avoir un impact significatif sur
la vie réelle  la vie des gens la vie des
civils s'il vous plaît ne faites pas de dépression
nerveuse je vous sens un peu le stress
est descendu nous trouverons une solution
ensemble j'espère
donc qu'internet a une forte capacité à
fournir des résultats positifs il a
la capacité de fournir des connaissances gratuites
l'éducation et la croissance de millions de
personnes dans le monde prenons un
exemple et la plus belle chose
au monde  connaissance au Moyen Âge
il aurait fallu toute une vie
à quelqu'un pour créer une encyclopédie
Wikipédia équivaut à 17 000 et cyclopaedia
et n'a pris que 15 ans pour le créer
représente la plus grande encyclopédie qui
ait jamais été créée
depuis le début de l'humanité et
c'est librement  des milliers de
personnes accessibles peuvent contribuer à ces
articles et des milliards de personnes
peuvent apprendre avec Wikipédia et tout cela
grâce au Web et à sa merveilleuse
capacité à connecter les personnes et les
appareils Internet a tellement de pouvoir et il
évolue constamment
qu'il  a la capacité de faire le bien mais
aussi de faire le mal dans la vraie vie avec l'
imagination avec la méthode de la vieille école qu'un
criminel peut avoir la capacité de planifier une
attaque contre une banque et de voler de l'argent
au comptoir de la banque mais bon allez
cela nécessiterait beaucoup de planification et
n'affecterait qu'une banque et seulement certains
clients du réservoir et à la fin le
gars a une probabilité d'être codé
mais avec inte  rnet ah, les criminels
ont maintenant le potentiel de voler beaucoup d'
argent et de vendre des milliers de
cartes de crédit volées en même temps en ligne et
ont probablement beaucoup moins de chances d'
obtenir une asymétrie de code essentiellement
Internet peut permettre à l'industrie de réaliser
des connaissances mais il peut aussi
industrialiser le  la criminalité
sous nos yeux une guerre se déroule
c'est une cyber guerre n'est même pas une question
c'est un fait le cyber est maintenant considéré comme un
cinquième domaine de guerre par l'OTAN
avec la terre ici la mer et l'espace avec la terre l'
air la mer et l'espace ça  la forme traditionnelle
de guerre et les règles d'engagement ont
été définies pendant des siècles depuis que les gens
font la guerre la vraie guerre et ces définitions
sont largement acceptées
mais il n'y a pas de
définition simple dans le cyber-monde c'est un
problème les lignes ont été complètement
floues et c'est pourquoi  il y a tellement de
désordre qu'il faut maintenant
tout redéfinir je vais vous poser une
question c'est quoi la définition d'un
vol sur internet  quelle est la
définition de la propriété sur Internet
quelle partie d'internet appartient à
quel pays comment définir une violation
de la souveraineté nationale sur internet
et peut-être la dernière et la plus ridicule
question quelle est l'attaque sur
internet nous devons tout redéfinir
la définition formelle ne fonctionne pas ce manque
de définitions crée des tensions entre les
nations et c'est une échelle qui s'intensifie
rapidement et déjà toute guerre sur le
terrain s'accompagne d'un cyber-
sabotage dans le même temps la
cyber-guerre a la capacité de créer des
armes de destruction massive et même
nations détruites jusqu'à ce que nous définissions les
règles que nous ne pouvons pas avancer pour que
la résolution pacifique de ce
problème soit complètement claire Internet
ne devrait pas être un champ de bataille sans
règles où seuls les plus forts survivent n
stein a dit je ne sais pas avec quelles
armes la troisième guerre mondiale  avec du boeuf sera
pensé mais la guerre mondiale 4 sera combattue
avec de l'épaisseur et de la pierre, ce qui signifie que cette guerre que
nous voyons en ce moment devant  de nos
yeux pourraient avoir le pouvoir de finalement
détruire l'humanité comme dans une vraie
vie civilisée, les gens ou les pays
ne devraient pas avoir le droit de riposter
ou d'
agir sans aucune règle d'engagement ou
possibilité d'avoir un litige ou d'essayer
de résoudre le problème par  peut-être la
diplomatie ou essayer de vous plaider son
code peut-être aux Nations Unies avant
de commencer une guerre peut-être que vous pouvez aller aux
Nations Unies et sonner ensemble et
au début c'est simplement une question de
définition et souhaite mon avis est que
donner une définition précise est  la
première étape nécessaire vers la création d'
un Internet plus pacifique, ce sera
ma conclusion, donc au lieu de regarder les
gens renforcer leurs capacités pour créer une cyber-
guerre, nous devons tous ensemble agir pour
construire une cyber-paix, merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]